ces images font partie du quotidien des
amériques
ce jeudi dans la petite ville de bryan
au texas un homme ouvre le feu dans un
magasin d'ameublement
bilan un mort et plusieurs blessés dont
quatre grièvement
quelques heures plus tôt joe biden
présente à la maison blanche des mesures
ciblées visant à limiter la
prolifération des armes à feu notamment
une loi intitulée signal d'alarmé
permettant aux autorités de saisir
temporairement les armes à feu
d'individus considérés comme dangereux
par la justice l'idée que nous avons
tant de personnes qui meurent chaque
jour de la violence des armes à feu en
amérique cela ternit l'image de notre
nation je veux voir une loi nationale
signal d'alarmé ainsi qu'une régie cela
sion pour inciter les états à promulguer
leurs propres lois signal d'alarmé
aujourd'hui je demande au ministère de
la justice de publier un modèle de loi
signal d'alarmé afin que les états
puissent commencer dès maintenant à
élaborer leurs propres lois
autre mesure annoncée lutter contre les
armes fantôme fabriqué de manière
artisanale et qui n'ont pas de numéro de
série
au total ce sont six décret qui ont été
annoncés mais leur portée reste faible
joe biden ne pouvant faire adopter au
congrès des actions plus audacieuses en
raison de la très courte majorité
parlementaire des démocrates
2 le congrès peut faire beaucoup plus
pour contribuer à cet effort et il peut
le faire dès maintenant des membres du
congrès ont offert beaucoup de pensées
de prière mais ils n'ont pas adopté une
seule nouvelle loi fédérale pour réduire
la violence liés aux armes à feu assez
de prière il est temps d'agir
les armes à feu un sujet ultra-sensible
aux états unis et qui divise
l'ancien président donald trump a reçu
des dizaines de millions de dollars pour
ces deux campagnes présidentielles de la
national rifle association le puissant
lobby protégeant le droit de posséder de
porter des armes
un droit fondamental pour de nombreux
américains joe biden a d'ailleurs assuré
qu'aucune des mesures dévoilées n'en
piété sur le second amendement de la
constitution en janvier 2021
plus de deux millions d'armes ont été
vendus outre-atlantique
c'est 80 % de plus par rapport à janvier
2020 une frénésie reflétant les
inquiétudes des américains dans un
climat politique et sanitaire très
tendues depuis le début de l'année aux
états unis
plus de onze mille personnes ont déjà
été tués par une arme à feu